it's my pleasure to introduce the
executive vice president of the AI and
research team at Microsoft dr. Harry
Shum well hello everyone good afternoon
thank you for joining us today here in
San Francisco exactly a year ago at San
Francisco we introduced this new
division of the Microsoft called the
Microsoft ai in the research and we
actually have the mission to democratize
AI for everyone so it has been a very
exciting year in the 2017 and there has
been we expect it and they delivered to
be in a very exciting year so I'm here
to share some of the progress with you I
appreciate this opportunity to show you
especially some very practical ways that
AI is helping everyone to improve our
lives so everyone is talking about AI
nowaday but AI is really not new you
know AI was really the something that
really the automated goal that four
brilliant minds people like Alan Turing
you know those people you imagine that
someday if we have this unbelievable
computing power
what could we really do the first thing
that Alan Turing really imagined was
doing AI is really mimicking in the
human intelligence and that the
Microsoft's our very own Bill Gates you
know when he created Microsoft Research
20 60 years ago you know he imagined
that in a some day computers could see
hear talk and understand the human
beings you know that's really
generalized the AI and AI is now
happening fast
you know why is that Timmy's released
three forces that converging to make
this thing happen it's really the big
data in the morning always aware who is
IOT and everything and the massive
computing power especially with the
clouds but most recently especially with
bricks through algorithms like deep
learning a deep neural nets that really
moved a eye from the labs to the
mainstream so too
we are going to talk to you about
everyday AI it's really you know the AR
is available you know to everyone
everywhere you know and whatever you do
in your personal and professional life
so how a I is going to help but in many
ways if you just read articles in the
general press AI probably has gotten a
bad reputation
you know because much of the AI
discussing is about you know humans
versus machines but not enough about AI
potentials we know AI will transform
every business you know help in every
life and potentially solve some of those
societal challenges that we all face and
you might ask that that's all sounds
great but what about the Microsoft way I
was so unique about what we do at the
Microsoft about AI well we believe that
AI know comes down to one thing people
AI will amplify human ingenuity making
people the heroes and the driving our
healthy connection between humans and
machines that's what we believe at
Microsoft
after that's really about the Microsoft
mission that is empower every person and
every organization on the planet to
achieve more now I would even add with
AI it's really a powerful machine and
the not too long ago our CEO Satya
Nadella shared our worldview that is the
intelligent the clouds and the
intelligent edge infused by AI you know
in a way it's really about the
ubiquitous computing and the ambient
intelligence finally happening with pcs
phones and the monomer IOT devices just
the imagine that you walk into any room
you know you walk to your speaker you
walk to your screen or you don't even
even realize that those things they
happen in the existing in the room then
you can already you know talk to katana
to get things done you know maybe across
the room with the help of far feel the
cameras
the far few the speakers so our goal is
really to help everyone everywhere and
take advantage of AI every day so that
is exactly why Saki and I actually
created our AI in the research division
and a little over a year ago it has been
a really exciting year and with more
than 8,000 researchers and engineers to
working together very closely and we
making greedy progress and the in
particular will leverage the talent and
the technology coming out of our
Microsoft research labs by accelerating
the cycle from research to the product
and the take a quick look at the video
about some exciting things that we have
been doing last year
you
actually you know how we even help
people you know without the voices how
they can communicate using AI and
clearly I could use some help we're here
to is oh yeah products and into the
hands
[Music]
it's great to see ideas and technologies
that have come back in the middle of our
products and into the hands of our users
you have lunch with Tony at CJ's from
12:30 to 1:30 p.m. it's changing the way
that we work with the land and it's
changing the way the land works for us
[Music]
top and left edge is not visible called
steady lease agreement
[Music]
hey Cortana what's my schedule today AI
is gonna change everyday life
our goal is that we make it a lot better
for people
[Applause]
[Music]
well this is of course there's just a
small sample of you know so many things
happening in Microsoft a I&R and I want
to explain to you know those areas that
we actually make investments there are
really five things that we do in
Microsoft a inr and we started with
Microsoft Research and there was a lot
of groundbreaking AI technologies there
that would build a lot of AI products in
the products like in the ping and the
katana now helping you in with everyday
lives and we infusing AI into all
Microsoft products you know with Windows
in the office and many others and we
built in the AI platforms it's really a
truly a cloud in the AI platform that
will can help Microsoft developers and
the ponders to build their AI
applications and we also see incredible
opportunities there with AI solutions
practically you know every vertical in
the industry is going to be disrupted
you know whether it's healthcare or
transportation and every horizontal
business processes what is marketing
sales or customer support and will be
disrupted by AI so we see incredible
opportunities there but let me first of
all show you a few highlights the the
coolest technology we have developed
from MSR Microsoft Research you know
getting into the real products the first
example I want to talk to you is on
speech recognition just a few months ago
we announced that we for the first time
ever now we actually have the speech
recognition system that match in a human
parity in terms of error rate there has
been this you know standard the data set
in the United States called a
switchboard data set that was initially
in a set up by DARPA in the 25 years ago
so the human error rate is around 5.1
percent I'm not even talking about the
ordinary humans who I'm talking about
the professionals who do transcript you
know who is the deep neural net with
massive computing power and with the
brilliance of our researchers so we
finally enriched in the human parity in
the 5.1% in the second area I want to
talk to you
is actually machine reading
comprehension or natural language
understanding last year
we acquired that this montreal-based
deep learning company called the maluma
you know they do you know amazing work
you know in reading and the writing and
the machine reading comprehension you
will see more on the moment loop our
technology is getting to Microsoft
products in office in being and other
places the third area is actually in
machine translation so we have been
doing machine translation for long
timing in our research labs but now you
can get machine translation in many many
products a few years ago we shipped the
machine translation in Skype translator
last year we actually shipped a
Microsoft translator in iOS and other
mobile apps and the just a month ago you
know with great partnership with the
highway now we're actually shipping
machine translator in those highways
flagship phones like may 10 and clearly
that you know with all those comparison
data we see that we now have the most
accurate machine translator on any
mobile phones today actually the
highways made them so those are the
really exciting things you know in you
know you research with the technology
and we move into mainstream products and
I want to talk about AI platform as well
just imagine what would like that if all
the developers could use all those cool
technology that we have in Microsoft and
from our labs what if we actually make
them available especially through our
cloud platform so we actually have one
of the most comprehensive cloud plus AI
platforms on the market you know there
are really three pieces that I want you
to understand as we talk about AI
platforms this is the services that we
can offer and is the infrastructure is
AI on data and the AI compute and
there's also tools like Visual Studio
Tools Visual Studio you know choose for
AI that we recently shipped and there is
limited a time today I'm going to know
just a deep dive into some of the
services that way I actually already
shipping so first of all I'd like to
share with you that you know more than
you know
760,000 developers are already using
Microsoft cognitive services and this is
a great set of web api's you know
developers can just take them and weave
into their own applications and it's
really great to see the mix of the
customers like a Mosin course and the
UPS or a healthcare how they have been
using Microsoft's cognitive services and
we really want to help every developer
to become an AI developer it's not only
just our partners at the Microsoft that
we use cognitive services to to create a
unique user experiences one of my
favorite is this little app called the
CAI we actually launched in July it's an
app using computer vision AI technology
to help the blind and the visually
impaired and it's amazing to see that
more than a hundred thousand downloads
already happens and it's it has a
reading of 4.8 you know it's really very
touching to me you know how you know we
can actually create the apps that people
really depend on and this greedy
response from the community and today we
are releasing even more greater features
you know for you know seeing AI app such
as currency recognition color
recognition and Elida detection I
encourage you to take time after this
and stop by their booths and they check
out and you will learn in the degree to
use the design questions there you know
how you can even take those technology
helping people who couldn't really see
very well you know it makes you think
about the design very differently you
know like using different modalities to
help so this is just a one example the
other thing we very feel very very good
about that we know you know it's really
helpful to the developers is that among
all those 30 you know api's were already
shipped one of them is called the
language of understanding you know
service is called the Lewis you know
that is really really you know pocketing
very very popular and the customers like
it Dixon's Carphone say
and the human interact and we really
appreciate their help you know giving us
the feedback and helped us to get the
product to certain quality you know
today you know I'm very happy to
announce that you know Lewis now is GA
is generally available so it's very very
exciting and another thing and I want to
talk about today you know helping the
developers is actually as you about
services you know many many companies
you know companies like a progressive
Unilever publicist you know they want to
be the bots and the apps to interact
with the customers with the employees
the much like you know just you know we
talk to each other just like a humans
and we offer the as you about the
service not only help you to create the
BOTS but also help you to deploy the
bots and also help you to run your BOTS
and we already have 240,000 developers
using as use pod services even in the
preview format but today we're
announcing that it's gianna so it's very
exciting and of course you know we
realize that you know as we develop an
AI you know we really have to drive the
connection with the AI community and the
to democratize AI is not just the one
company's responsibility is really the
whole community's responsibility I'll
give you a few examples here what we
have been doing at the Microsoft the
first example is this intermediate
representation this thing called onyx
it's got an open neural network exchange
project that we started with Facebook in
September it's really in the open source
format that enables those AI frameworks
to interoperate with each other so this
is example number one the second example
is actually what we have been doing with
Amazon is called the glue on so glue on
is that the AI fin at the free Maki
interface you know there are so many AI
in the frameworks out there and we don't
want the developers to be confused you
know they can choose any of the three
book and they can get help from Amazon
and Microsoft estado is something called
the glue on to bypass all those
complexity without sacrificing any of
those speed
and the third example I want to share
with you is that you know we have been
making a lot of investments you know
with Microsoft venture in those leading
AI companies emerging the companies
there and there's some great examples I
show here like elemental AI and the
Banzai and the text so those are very
exciting activities that we do and
another thing I want to share with you
is that we see those vertical solutions
and very very exciting and especially
one example you know we actually really
push hard at Microsoft that together
with our partners that is the business
AI solutions for customer services and
I'm sure you know at some point of your
life you use customer services and there
and typically you know you use customer
services you spend a lot of time in
uyuni and you still get the frustrated
this is where AI can really come in to
help you know the system oh can you
imagine is that actually you can have a
virtual agent and you have an aging
assistance and the conversation of
management tool to bring all those
things together we have great partners
like HP mesas and the Australian
Government's Department of Human
Services already working with us to
deliver those fantastic solutions so
those are really exciting things that we
have been doing in Microsoft era in our
but today I want to focus on everyday AI
I want you to talk about what are those
the practical ways so what are the
products that we are already shipping
with new and the cool AI features to
really help everyone everyday so let me
start with one of those most pervasive
forms of AI is called a search and you
might say so what's new in search I have
been using such a for long long time and
I would argue that such has really moved
on is no longer just 10 blue links now
in a search can be so powerful with the
concepts you know with dialogues with
many more things and the Microsoft we
have Buda being really beyond just a
search engine Bing has helped to build
the Microsoft cloud services with all
those back
infrastructure and the beam has become
the foundation for AI for our company
and beam might be just a much bigger
than you even think about and we
actually launched the ping in year 2007
and it is now powering over a third of
the PC web search traffic in the United
States and the continues to grow you
know in the US and the worldwide and it
also powers some such experiences from
many of our partners including Yahoo now
is Verizon ll in the Amazon and the
multilingual
ability of a Twitter and apples image
search of course you know Search Search
we have developed some really
foundational AI technologies especially
in natural language understanding so
this is really you know a lot of a lot
of things that we can depend on for the
future ai development so today I'm very
very excited to introduce three new
intelligent search capabilities that we
shipping immediately with being the
first thing is what we call the
intelligent answers so that utilizes the
machine reading comprehension to present
you with multiple perspectives
share snippets of multiple answers
verify answers across multiple sources
and the translates data into easy to
understand the concepts so it's not only
you see more the more those answers
popping up at the top of surgeries out
the page from Bing but you will get a
lot more perspective as well second
intelligent the image research that
enables you to search image within the
images you know by leveraging object
recognition so that's another cool way
to find what you are really looking for
the third new feature about the new
intelligent search in Bing is what I
call the conversational search that
really provides the intelligent
suggestions to help you to find what you
are
looking for very often we understand
that we want to search for something but
it's really hard to express what if we
actually turned that experience engine
more a dialog so that's the third thing
called the conversational search please
welcome Christina bear from the ping
team to show you some cool demos
Christina thanks Harry at the center of
AI is data it powers everything and at
Microsoft we have unique data graphs
world knowledge with Bing and work
knowledge with the rest of the Microsoft
graph but really the magic happens when
you make sense of all of this
information we've evolved from simple
searches and keyword matching to using
advanced AI techniques like machine
reading comprehension that uses deep
learning to understand the meaning
behind words we also need really
powerful hardware in order to process
these AI models like deep neural
networks we've partnered with Intel to
create industry-leading agility and
performance with FPGA chips that allow
us to read and understand billions of
documents in milliseconds so how does
this apply to your everyday today I'm
going to show you how a AI enables
intelligent search in a few ways one
with intelligent answers Bing for
business
intelligent image search and a new
search paradigm that is for more
conversational search let's start with
something rather mundane like finding a
movie to watch for the holidays so
instead of a simple keyword search I'm
going to use something with more natural
language like movies directed by
Spielberg starring Tom Hanks let's do
Tom Hanks okay
this answer is specific to my actual
query it filtered out TV shows and there
are other partnerships but it still
included a movie that they're doing
together in January use with beings vast
understanding of the world people and
entities and how they relate to each
other
AI enables us to power more rich and
patent complete answers now let's say
I'm doing some research on something a
bit more controversial I'm a vegan and I
a lot of flack from my family for being
an annoying kale pusher I want to be
prepared for the inevitable holiday
table debate with my cousin so I'm gonna
do a search for facts about kale this
result here is a multi source answer
being uses AI to bring together
information from multiple different
websites into one place and at Microsoft
we believe it's important to understand
where information comes from
so although we provide quick access and
links to content we're also really
careful to make sure we also include
sources so this way I can feel confident
about my advocacy of kale and if I want
to be super prepared and understand both
sides of an issue because we don't live
in a world of absolutes I can do a query
like also using natural language like is
kale good for you this is a multi
perspective answer Bing shows alternate
viewpoints that you can understand both
sides of an issue so on one side I have
Pro kale and then the other side I have
a cautionary tale of why too much kale
is bad so that I don't have to live in a
bubble where everything about kale is
amazing and if I really want to embrace
this kale loving lifestyle I should
probably take up yoga or pilates but I
don't actually really know the
difference between them so if I do a
search for difference between yoga and
Pilates I get this comparison answer
being is taking comparisons a feature
typically found in product or shopping
based scenarios and have expanded it to
a wider query set we use machine reading
comprehension to read the web and
understand entities and their aspects in
order to compare differences between
items so I think I know yeah seems like
it's more my jam so let's go ahead and
pick that and I've heard a lot about
yoga retreats in Costa Rica so but I
don't actually have a sense for how big
is this is a relational answer in
addition to showing the actual square
miles I'm also told it's about twice the
size of Massachusetts which is
incidentally my home state so I have a
good site a sense of what that means
being has taken two used AI and add some
perspective into information so not only
we're using AI to search across the
billions of documents in the web we're
also using AI to make information more
understandable because while the
engineer me geeks out on all this data
the designer and me knows that real user
delight comes from making data makes
sense so all of these new experiences
multiple sources multiple perspectives
comparisons and relational answers they
all make up a we call intelligent
answers so all of these everyday ki
capabilities are awesome but what if we
could apply them to the context of work
that's exactly what we've done with Bing
for business for starters let me just go
back to the Bing homepage because I'm
signed in with my Microsoft work account
at the bottom of my home page I can see
industry related news and that's
relevant to me a person in tech and
beyond this personalization let me show
you what the Microsoft graph and AI can
do for a workplace productivity so I
have a Microsoft holiday party coming up
and the fabulous Harry Shum is my
executive vice president so because I'm
signed in and I think for business
enabled I type in Harry's org and note
that I'm not using his last name but it
still provides me with the org chart for
the right Harry even though there are
plenty of great Harry's that work at
Microsoft also in the same experience
our web results that are related to the
query
Harry's org so Bing for business brings
together the best of corporate internet
search with the best of web search all
into one experience so if I do something
a little bit more complicated like how
much vacation do I get because of the
FPGA FPGA chip I get answers in
milliseconds and if for something supers
obscure I can search for
can I hire my cousin machine reading
comprehension powers this answer what
you'll notice here is that cousin isn't
even mentioned in the passage
that's because Bing knows that cousin is
a family member and understands the
meaning behind words to get me the right
answer not that I would hire my Kaela
hating cousin anyway so for this holiday
party I'm also going to want to find
something festive to wear but it is a
work event so I'm gonna search for work
appropriate holiday cocktail dress and
I'm gonna go to image or image vertical
and then this one looks appropriately
festive Bing intelligent image uses
computer vision an AI technique in order
to find dresses that look just like this
one with direct links to buy so they can
look around and do some price
comparisons and the other thing it does
is our object detection allows me to
Reese cope this query on just this
necklace so now I can find necklaces
that look very similar to one in this
photo again with direct links to buy
being is intelligent search that saves
time and money okay inde is just into
intelligent answers Bing for business
and intelligent image search we're also
using AI to make the search box itself
more conversational with an interactive
guided search experience we hear a lot
from customers that they wished search
could just complete their sentences if I
do a vague search like I'm feeling
stressed which may or may not be because
of this demo I get this guided web
guided search experience so I get
obviously the web results you'd expect
from a search engine I get our answers
but then up top what you'll see here is
that it prompts for additional query
refinement so I can go through and pick
stress management and then breathing
exercises and then I can also kind of
expand to see my previous results what's
different here is that search is
building upon the last search so it's a
little bit more conversational a little
bit more personalized we're able to do
with this is get you better answers
faster this is a new search
paradigm we are amplifying our extensive
knowledge graph with AI our expertise in
conversational AI with our box like
shall I sands o are brought together
with our vast data enable enables thing
to create a new interactive search
experience that gets you better answers
faster if I do another example for let's
see Seattle verse I'm prompted for
popular rivalry so I'm gonna select the
Rams here and then here you'll see an
answer of an upcoming game on the 17th
in addition to web links and this
awesome answer I can also see who being
predicts to win so we're predicting the
Rams will win for by 51% being uses
search social and other relevant data
signals in order to make predictions on
sports reality TV shows and more and if
I do another really ambiguous search
like set default without any context of
what default I'm trying to set I'm
prompted with very popular things that
people set to false or conversational
search uses large scale machine learning
so this experience is only going to get
better over time
AI learns from user engagement so we're
really excited for the future of
conversational search what I've shown
you today intelligent answers Bing for
business
intelligent image search and a new
conversational guided search is just a
small sampling of how we are using AI to
create intelligent search all of these
experiences are either live today or
starting to roll out today thank you let
me turn it back over to Harry thank you
very much Christina well I hope you
liked those demos and they are you may
not realize this you know people really
underestimates you know how much time
they spend searching for the right
information even more so you know how
much time they actually continue search
for whether this is the right
information so this is where in a
natural language understanding machine
reading comprehension is just going to
be so important and it's doing the work
for you
and that is another thing that is really
important is that you also want to know
that as people talk about this kind of
information where is the conversation
and you add some credibility to all this
kind of interesting topics so call out
the days of those endless blue links but
today's search is really about the real
answers you know real perspectives and
the real conversations that's why I'm so
excited to announce today a new
partnership with Reddit we are working
together to bring relevant ready the
conversations to answer simple and
bringing big entities to Reddit to talk
about those unique applications of AI at
the intersection of social news and the
conversations and the search let me
welcome up Alexis Ohanian co-founder of
Reddit Alexis thank you so much Harry
there you go
grab a beer hello everyone good day this
is pretty exciting if you can believe it
before reddit was the front page of the
Internet it was a fun little project
that my college buddy and I were
starting in a small little apartment in
Medford Massachusetts this was back in
2005 we just graduated we had no idea
what we were doing but we knew enough
and had people who believed in us enough
to take a chance and read it today now
has hundreds of millions of users 340
million monthly active users and about
two years ago my co-founder and our CEO
Steve came back and it was really
instrumental in bringing him back to get
the company reset and to start doing a
lot of the things that basically we
wished we had done maybe a decade ago
read it was sold in 2006 the kind of
Nass that's now independent and for the
last two years has been shipping a ton
of code building some really amazing
partnerships and building up a team
including a very formidable BD team a
couple of whom are here who basically
took a chance on us a couple years ago
because there was no BD process and said
we want to be a part of this we see the
potential and what you're seeing here
today with this partnership with
Microsoft is actually a really good
example
of just how far we've come in actually a
pretty short time so while reddit the
website is 12 years old
reddit Inc the new entity is really only
about two three years old and we're so
proud to be announcing this partnership
here with Microsoft and Bing today so
giving you a little bit of the backstory
told you a bit about myself I'm
co-founder of reddit and you know I've
never really understood the scale of
Reddit which I know sounds crazy I'm a
co-founder one of the original users but
I never really understood the scale of
Reddit until this partnership because
when you're in the middle of it all it's
kind of hard to really understand the
numbers behind just how many
conversations and just how many
communities exist on the reddit platform
and look if I can't navigate it or grok
it then heaven help everyone else and so
the last two and a half three years have
really been a cause for us to make
reddit more accessible to the masses if
you haven't used the read adapt I
encourage you to do so it's only a year
old if you can believe it and my wife
takes credit for having sparked it
because one of our first conversations
was her confessing to me she had no idea
what read it was immediately doing a
search on her phone not finding an app
and thinking I was a liar but that's the
world we live in today right we very
quickly look at first
reddit didn't have a mobile presence to
speak of didn't even have a mobile
website now we do it's beautiful the
desktop is you may have seen Steve
unveil at web summit is also getting a
redesign it will look beautiful it will
look modern but every one of these are
steps toward getting this great content
in front of as many people as possible
as excessively as possible and this
partnership with Bing is helping us do
that on a whole nother level and just
some of the numbers like I said three or
thirty million monthly active users on
reddit now ten point seven million post
submissions per month it's a very active
user base 2.8 million comments per day
reddit is the one social network that is
not anti-social it's the one place where
you'll actually read the comments first
before looking at the content because
they provide so much value the reason
those comments provide so much value is
because the hundreds of millions of
users like probably many of you all
upload the good ones down vote the bad
ones and a real
brilliant algorithm that Steve came up
with as a 21 year old sorts the good
from the bad and this is a pretty
remarkable thing actually just by a
quick show of hands how many of you in
the room are redditors it's okay if
you're using reddit right now I will
take it personally okay thank you
uploads to all of you and also thank you
for being so brave that you're willing
out yourselves is the least productive
people in this room that is that is
impressive over a hundred and thirty
eight thousand active communities for
whatever your passion whatever your love
whether it is the Seattle Seahawks
whether it is sneakers hopefully there's
a few of you sneaker it's here you can
appreciate the off whites that I'm
wearing right now but these are the
communities whose opinions we actually
care about I don't care what my friends
from college think about shoes because
they have terrible taste I care about
what this community of people this peer
group that I care about thinks and isn't
that how we humans have worked all along
right people come to Reddit to see this
this breadth of different communities to
get advice to get feedback to get a
better understanding of their world and
the things they care about whether they
are shopping for beard care products yes
there are a number of beard care
communities are slash beards being one
of my favorites if you don't like beards
that's fine they'll grow on you okay all
right that's fine or maybe or maybe your
new parent like I was and really really
worried because every photo every parent
I know puts on the Internet is perfect
and pristine because that's the image we
want to show to the world but when
you're kids screaming at 4 a.m. you're
not thinking let me take a selfie you're
thinking I need someone to commiserate
with and the dadit's community on reddit
was the place for me and for so many
more whether they need skin care advice
our size skin care of addiction could
have saved my teen years I would have
found accutane a lot faster but it
didn't exist there was no place to go to
to talk about this stuff because these
are the conversations people can really
only have on a platform like reddit with
that scale and so all this amazing
content is sitting there it's sitting
there so much content so engaging we
average about 12 minutes per session
right this is stuff that is highly
engaging but as long as it is just on
Reddit we know that we're still missing
out on a much broader audience that we
know can benefit from it
and so we're thinking how do we find
partners who can get us to a massive
audience and a massive mainstream reach
Bing there you go
this partnership with Microsoft is just
the beginning and we've got three big
things around the intelligent search
experience that we're unveiling today
but as I've told everyone here in the
little conversations leading up to this
this is just the start so like I said
three big things that are gonna
integrate reddit content more directly
more beautifully more helpfully into
being search results the first of which
ask me any things this brand is who's
probably as well-known as reddit itself
many platforms have tried to copy the
model but they've all failed the magic
is in the context a crowd-sourced QA on
its surface doesn't seem really
interesting until you put it in the
context of a community and until you can
see what happens when the science
community gets a chance to talk to an
expert like Jane Goodall and ask their
very best and very smartest questions
and they don't have to be celebrities
right one of those popular AMAs of all
time was a vacuum repairman it's true he
actually came back on recently he's now
a vacuum repair manager he got a
promotion in the last few years that's
not a joke I'm serious and it may be no
small part thanks to the reddit AMA he
spent 24 hours answering literally every
question someone could post about a
vacuum and believe me there are a lot of
fascinating questions about vacuums from
like what's the weirdest thing you've
found in a vacuum to like I have this
particular model and it makes this were
were were noise every 30 seconds right
these are conversations you won't find
anywhere else but it turns out are
actually really valuable and really
nuanced and really special and we know
that there are people whether they know
it or not who are searching for this
every day on being but now we're
providing them a world-class experience
to find it secondly reddit content
itself as well as the responses around a
being users question now this is fun
right we're seeing more and more queries
now phrased as questions and part of
that's the rise of voice and part of
that is just the fact that like we're
just getting used to talking to the
we're talking to the robot and expecting
a good answer the challenge here is
there's a lot of nuance when you're
asking these kinds of open and inquest
and reddit is the largest data set in
the english-speaking world of vetted
nuanced responses the greatest NFL play
is a very different answer depending on
whether you're asking it in New England
or in Seattle and the NFL fans that I'm
talking about so like what is so so
important here is that we have this data
set we've had it actually for a very
long time it gets bigger and bigger
every day but we ourselves are still
building a data team within Reddit just
to understand all the myriad of things
we have to worry about we needed some
partners who could bring in the heavy
lifting around artificial intelligence
who were really comfortable dealing with
a massive data set and again it came
back to Microsoft and then finally the
third thing making reddit communities
and their top content these are also
known as sub reddits more accessible to
user who runs that being query find some
results and and whether they're looking
for cute animal photos which is a great
reason or looking for cooking advice
they find a rich arresting visual look
into that community we have so many
people who visit reddit who may not even
be fully aware of how much is there
beneath the surface and having these
search results be obvious and beautiful
and visual is one more step to getting
them aware of it so we wanted to help
people find the great content on reddit
being has been such a great partner in
doing this and like I said AMAs are such
there was such low-hanging fruits one of
the things that's never been done before
that we're thrilled to be announcing
here is actually now for the first time
in Bing search results you will see
upcoming AMAs now this seems this seems
sort of obvious but it's actually
something that we've never done before
and so a very common complaint we hear
from people is oh my goodness how did I
miss fill in the blank was doing this
AMA it stuff right because if you don't
know in advance then maybe you find out
about it while it's going on or maybe
you've read about it a day later and
your friend's Facebook page or maybe you
read about it a week later on BuzzFeed
but one way or one way or another you
wish you had known in advance and so
it's really exciting we now actually can
have this as a part of these search
results so Leah Remini has done a couple
AMAs now around her documentary series
on A&E around Scientology and so here's
an example as you'll see on the right
rail queue
with Leah Remini upcoming date time and
this is all being pulled from reddit and
so when someone runs that query because
I heard something about her or her
documentary series they know this event
is happening they can set their alarm
they can do what they need to do to make
sure they're a part of this moment and
this is I mean a transformative thing
for us we have so many people who find
their gateways to Reddit through these
AMAs because if you haven't necessarily
heard of reddit you've heard of that
celebrity or that influencer or that
maybe you also own a vacuum and that you
want to learn from and hear from and
this becomes a great gateway and so this
is using an example of a past AMA as
though or upcoming in case you're trying
to set your calendars for it that's it's
not gonna work cuz it was November 29th
but you'll see that's how it's gonna
look but then there's also the leveling
up of how past AMAs are appearing in
search results jane goodall I wasn't
lying she did an amazing job with an AMA
on reddit asking getting asked questions
that are the best of an audience that is
very interested in science
now you could cut this a bunch of
different ways right we see AMA is
happening across all the different
communities on reddit so the question is
she'll get there are a little different
a little more nuanced and the questions
she gets from the environment community
which are a little different than
questions she might get from the two
x-chromosomes community which are a
little different from the question she
might get from the etc.etc communities
Bing can handle all of this and through
robots that I don't understand and
certainly would not challenge in a game
of chess figure out what the best
results should be and present them in a
way that's digestible and accessible for
a user so you can see the QA would Jane
Goodall the top comment the top response
believe me I've heard a few times that
the current desktop version of Reddit is
a little hard to grok at first glance
these beautiful results let someone
who's running a big query find this
great content dive into it instantly and
see the very best of what the reddit
community has to offer and really what
the bested Goodall and others have to
offer you'll start seeing top AMAs in
these search results you're the best
AMAs of all time I have to admit I
didn't even know I've missed about half
of these and it's been a busy year but
now they exist here with beautiful
thumbnails right up top for anyone to
come see right this is more
accessibility into the rich wealth of
Reddick
that we know is there but isn't always
the most accessible and this is part of
a much bigger rollout for us that
carousel will continue to update and
we'll continue to see the very best of
these QA results these reddit
conversations that bubble up to the top
and so prospective some retic
conversations are interesting right
because like I said
reddit's the one place where
conversation actually happens online and
where the best stuff as determined by
that community bubbles up and this has
been fun for me because I've revisited
moments and times my life that I didn't
think I would ever again thanks to
Reddit we have millions of users across
a hundred thousand plus communities and
they understand nuance because it's a
human asking the question and a bunch of
humans answering it and the best stuff
being voted up this is great data for
the Bing team to start to learn what
really the best answers are for
questions that might not be the easiest
for a robot for instance how accurate is
HBO's band of brothers now this was
totally serendipitous when the Microsoft
team presented this to me I got really
excited Band of Brothers was the show
that Steve and I would be in John while
we were building reddit and we'd at the
end of a long workday we get on top of
the roof in Somerville and crack open a
couple beers and watch Band of Brothers
we obsessed over this series it's a
really really well done series and I was
a history major believe it or not and
with that history degree
I studied European history I still had
questions watching this and when I dive
onto the ask historians community on
reddit I actually have a window into the
very best historians history students
may be armchair historians imaginable
because this community actually self
curates they require citation for posts
and they can provide a really valuable
insight on a subject matter that has
shades of nuance write a question like
how accurate is HBO's band of brothers
is not a simple binary yes right it's a
well yeah in a lot of ways it is here's
what they got right here's what they got
wrong here's the thing that's pretty
disputed in here are two different
points of view now as humans we love
this especially if you like history this
is what we relish we get to dig into
this because there are different
perspectives robots don't work so well
with the nuance unless they have this
data and so now we're seeing results
that are actually helpful and valuable
and you see trending comments and look
it's it's like I am transported back to
those history classes in school with the
very best ideas being voted up and we're
seeing the same thing results even
around things that may seem pretty
obvious like why my pot isn't boiling
with water now look I know if you watch
it technically it's not supposed to
turns out that is not scientific fact
but if you've tried like I have to boil
one of those huge huge I just doing a
crawfish boil you ever tried it I mean
you put the filling in with water and
put it on high and you will find that it
actually takes a really long time
there's a whole community of people
frustrated wondering and asking Bing for
an answer to this and now they can
actually get really helpful results they
can get an understanding from a chemists
point of view from a science community
they can also get an understanding from
a chef's point of view and maybe some
tricks to help solve that little boiling
problem this is all about presenting
that grade content in a much more
accessible way to being users who may or
may not even be aware of reddit when
they're running the query because we
know this content is valuable and this
is special because we see this as a
window into to frankly help people
discover new communities they don't even
know they wanted to be a part of they
didn't even know they were into a
hundred thirty thousand communities
means a ton of opportunities for you to
find something that you love on reddit
and it's you know it's about cute
animals sometimes this is a window into
the awe community one of our largest
featuring lots of photos of cats and
dogs and other animals and now with this
wonderful first-class treatment when you
run when you see these results you
actually see a window in you see the
votes you see the comments you see
beautiful thumbnails you are invited
into a community now in a way that is
probably new to a lot of Internet users
because we're so used to a one-way
conversation now we're exposing them to
the magic of real real conversation on
reddit and maybe you would have gotten
confused otherwise I mean data is
beautiful on the surface seems like a
community all about saying how
attractive the Android from Star Trek is
and you grammar aficionados obviously
know that technically it should say data
are beautiful but we're not going to
nitpick
the data is beautiful communities
actually the largest community of data
visualization fans of stats fans all
they do is share datasets and
visualizations all the time it's a
fabulous community now it's showing up
in context in a beautiful way to see
what the trending aspects and trending
discussions are on that community and
directly linked to reddit posts and like
I said this is mutually beneficial it's
helping us bring a whole new even
broader swath of Internet users on to
Reddit in a really useful accessible
beautiful way and then it's also going
to power Bing search results so those
continue to get better and better over
time using data that only reddit has and
that's actually thanks to a lot of you
thanks to your comments and your upvotes
we know this and so now we can share it
we can make both of our platforms better
as a result and like I said from jump
this is just the start
reddit may be 12 years old on the
internet but it's really only a few
years old as a business and the growth
and the great great success we've had in
the last few years is just the beginning
this partnership is like a like a crown
jewel for us but we're not complacent we
know we still have a lot of work to do
and we have very big ambitions and this
just scratches the surface on our
relationship with Microsoft AI and
reddit data we're also launching today
here power bi so I've had to talk to cm
O's all over fortune 100 companies who
have been asking for a crystal ball
wouldn't we all like that to be able to
get in front of the watercooler
where the conversations the real
conversations are happening among the
people who we care most about about the
things we care most about and reddit is
the place whether you want to know what
the trending sneakers are before anyone
else or I mean I've had countless people
come up to me and just thanked me and
I've asked them why and they said are
such Bitcoin and I can only imagine it's
because six years ago they were on that
community seeing all the inertia seeing
all the traction buying an ample share
of Bitcoin at a weight cheaper price
than it is today and have benefited very
generously from it but whether you want
to know the trends for the latest
cryptocurrency that's going to pop
whether you want to know what make up
people are really hot for you we'll find
out on reddit first but historically
it's been really hard you've had to
actually spend lots of time being on
those communities being on the platform
and now thanks to this with power bi we
now have these business intelligence
modules to do the work for you the
robots are doing the hard stuff and so
the trends that you want to track the
the keywords do you want to follow any
of the brand insights you want to
monitor we're letting the robots to do
that work now and so we want all of
these people to get this data so that we
can give them the crystal ball turns out
it's been on reddit for a while we're
just really grateful now to have
Microsoft to help us actually bring it
to life to actually help us build that
crystal ball and we're really lucky to
Alex Remini who is our director of
business development and gnome Kaduri
was our head of data partnerships are
here and we've got a cool little booth
just around the corner so you can talk
to them you can ask them anything
regarding power bi or any of the stuff
that we've announced today but again I
can't stress enough this is just the
start
and this has been an exciting 2 3 years
now since coming back but the next 2 or
3 are gonna be even more amazing and I'm
grateful to Microsoft for helping be
such wonderful partners in this journey
so thank you it's really an exciting
partnership I just couldn't really think
about it any better win-win partnerships
imagine that you know what we can do
together
with 330 million in a redditor users and
the 450 million being users who
otherwise it's just amazing that we can
really do to use AI to transforms that
not only that the search experience but
also what does the web in the community
can all work together so I hope you have
a chance to really try this new Bing
experience with all those intelligent
answers and with perspectives and the
conversations this is a new is a new
norm as you think about the new users
search experience but I want to switch
gear a little bit in the talking about
another place where intelligence will
come up that is really intelligent
they're digital assistants katana I want
to talk about katana I'm sure by now you
have heard a lot of the intelligent
assistance you know popping
from know many many companies you
definitely have a question that in the
so what's so unique about the Microsoft
Cortana I tell you two things about the
Microsoft Cortana that's really unique
number one
Cortana is really designed for you to go
across your work life you work and life
and as you can imagine that the lines
between work and life are really blurry
just think about that you know your
email accounts that they use at home and
that you use their to work so this why
we actually design katana to become the
best digital assistant to help you to
get things done you know whether you're
the home at a worker on the go and for
example katana will help you to find the
emails and they remind you your
commitments you may or may not already
forgotten and the recommended meeting
times or shared accounts so this is why
that we actually have now the support to
really have helped you to work across
different email systems so we actually
now can work you know added it now Gmail
support for calendar and the email so
that katana can help you get across
multiple email systems so I'm very happy
to announce that you know we actually
you know have this ability today you
know in katana you will see a demo very
soon so the second thing very unique
about the katana I want to share with
you is that it's not really about our
own katana devices only so we really
want to bring katana to as many devices
as possible and the way for example
launched this Harman Kardon speaker
recently was a beautiful in a voice
quality and Aldus no digital assistant
quality and the user experience and we
also announced this partnership you know
katana and the Alexa you know with
Amazon because we actually believe that
it's important that we offer in a very
unique user experience especially across
walk in the life on different devices
but that's not all we also want the
katana to appear in as many applications
as possible you know what is Microsoft's
the only
those and the office and others and all
enjoy and iOS applications in other
platforms so this why you know I'm so
excited to announce in a two new mobile
launcher or Android platform our own
Microsoft launcher and cheetah mobile
and our public you know they actually
have one of those top the productivity
launcher in enjoy Google Play Store and
the cheetah mobile launcher will be
available immediate with our katana
embedded and the Microsoft launcher we
have katana capability in a couple of
months so this integrations with katana
is really you know we do that to help we
know more people across multiple
platforms it's really coming back to my
earlier point that is you know you think
about that the lines between what can
the life getting blurred why did you
need a system where did you need a
system so this is really you know our
commitment to help people to get things
down even faster
so one thing I want to remind everyone
is that you know as we design those
digital assistants like a katana it's
really about the conversational AI it's
really not just a bother you have one
question then you get an answer then you
get out of there it's really encourage
you to getting into the dialogue so I
want to invite Christina to come up to
show you some of those interesting no
katana demos Christina so first and
foremost Cortana is a fantastic
workplace productivity assistant it can
help with things that normally take a
lot of time and a lot of steps
one example is finding time with my very
busy VP Geordi hey Cortana set up a
meeting called FY 18 goals with Geordi
rebus looks like you and Georgie are
both free at 9:30 a.m. on Monday January
AIDS when would you like to meet 9:30
a.m. on January 8 okay
I've scheduled FY teen goals with you
and Geordi at 9:30 a.m. on Monday
January
is that right yes got it
January I told you he was busy before
today I would have wasted a lot of time
going back and forth trying to figure
out when we were both free but now with
Cortana because it understands my
calendar and Jordi's calendar it can
suggest the time that's best for both of
us beyond a pure workplace productivity
assistant we all know as Harry said that
the line between work and home they're
blurring more and more each day
the real value in Cortana is in its
ability to move across devices and
across the different aspects of our
lives it's difficult to schedule a work
trip if you don't know what's on your
personal calendar and we all know that
sometimes the most urgent email that you
receive during a work day is from a
family member or from a friend
Cortana summarizes across your different
email accounts hey Cortana what new
emails do I have you've got six new
emails in the last hour one from Adam
Kirk marked important three from Emma
Williams and two from Jordi rebus which
Centre do you want to hear more about
Adam place Adam Kirk email view about
Cirque Dreams holidays marked important
what a here--it yes please
it says don't forget to buy tickets for
your parents visit what do you think
about a Friday XO me what should I do
with this reply or nothing nothing
alright we're all really busy people but
because Cortana blends my work and
personal life by reaching across my
different email accounts I can take care
of things as they come up of course I
could set a reminder and take care of
this later but there is no time like the
present problem is I don't actually
remember when my parents are coming to
town hey Cortana find mom and dad on my
calendar you have mom and dad visiting
at Seattle from Wednesday December 20th
to Wednesday December 27th okay because
Cortana is about helping you wherever
you are
it supports integration across calendars
with office 365 Outlook and now even
Gmail hey Cortana help me find tickets
to Cirque Dreams holidays in Seattle on
December 22nd I have three skills that
can help you Ticketmaster gig seeker and
stub hub which do you want to use
Ticketmaster please okay opening
Ticketmaster I found Cirque Dreams
holidays in Seattle on December 22nd at
7:30 p.m. tickets are $40 to $80 do you
want to pick your seats or buy the best
seats available best seats available
please okay how many seats do you need
four please okay I found four seats
Rohde seats 6 to 9 sound good yes
okay I have four seats for Cirque Dreams
holidays at the Paramount Theater in
Seattle on Friday December 22nd at 7:30
p.m. the total comes out to 394 dollars
say confirmed to purchase confirm okay
you're all set
would you like me to add this to your
calendar yes please also invite Adam
okay
I've sent this event to Adam Kirk and
added it to your calendar thank you for
letting me get that taken care of now
let me walk you through some of the cool
things that just happened here instead
of me needing to know which specific
skill to ask for Cortana use skills
suggestion to connect me to the best
place to buy tickets and then connected
me to that third party skill and because
of my I have my credit card information
with Ticketmaster my purchase process
was a breeze Cortana then used a new
feature called skill training which
understands my overall intent to help me
find the next most relevant skill in
this case it was adding an event to my
calendar how great was that using my
voice
Cortana was able to help me be super
productive in both work and at home all
of this done hands-free this calendar
feature is available now the next
generation of our Cortana skills kit is
also available today and then email
features that demo today or will be
available next month but of course
Cortana can help you in more places than
just this great speaker here's a quick
look in all of the place some of the
places that Cortana can help you be more
productive and get things done across
windows edge Skype and the new mobile
launchers
hey Cortana play my dance mix
[Music]
[Applause]
I booked your workout for 6:00 p.m.
tonight can I get you a ride
[Music]
hey Cortana what's next it's really
amazing to see you know how katana has
evolved into really powerful in the
digital assistance in a way I've been
really thinking a lot in the Microsoft
and how to design a conversational AI
systems you know katana just one of them
another one I want to bring your
attention to you is actually chat BOTS
so we actually shifted the first to chat
bots in China about the three and a half
years ago it's called the showers in
China now actually she has about a
hundred million users in China and the
talking to her non average like 23 turns
and she's actually very very talented
you know in China and she's even hosting
a TV program on e news programming in
Shanghai was over 800 million viewership
and she recently actually in a
demonstrate her ability to write poems
she actually published a poetry book you
know amazing and that that helped over
you know help it is the Chinese users to
write over 2 million poems and just so
you understand that the scale the number
of poems that's more than all the poems
they ever published in the history of
China so that's the only thing China in
the in Japan at a year later we actually
launched in Japan called arena that she
had ballerina and it's even more popular
in Japan at 25 percent of Japanese
population have already talked to the
arena in Japan and she's also now
powering a chatbot in a for Nintendo's
Pokemon so and of course you know know
here right here in the United States as
you some of you might remember exactly a
year ago you know we celebrate the
arrival of zou I won't share but here in
the US you know in just a year I'm happy
to tell you that now we actually have a
sheer show has over a million users just
like ash allies and Arena and the zou
actually has developed several AI jus
even senses like voice recognition image
recognition and the social commenting
and the natural language understanding
people can now rhyme with zou in a rap
battle
and it's really amazing or challenging
her for a game of exploding kittens or
even interact with her newest uh friend
papi of a popular youtuber it's just
amazing things that you can do with that
with the chat box but then you might
have wonder so why did you pay so much
attention to chat bus let me just say
that chit chat is characteristic of
human beings just go home and think
about this so most of us are intelligent
agents today like a serial katana focus
on tasks accomplishing or IQ getting
star with the skill chain and chaining
like what they just saw from Christina's
demo it's fabulous it's really helping
get things done
but it is the emotional intelligence or
the EQ that enables sustain the
conversations at dialogues which you
will be critical to truly understand the
human users so by engaging with the
people you know much more social and the
personal level in our chat buzz now I
develop in their eq's so learning how to
react response and based on the data
that from those human interaction so
then we can take those learnings and
apply them to many other products so of
course you know you Microsoft not only
you know we do those conversational AI
products you know we also make sure that
our AI investments you know will be
infused into all Microsoft products and
services that drive deeper and more
personal experiences the first place we
start of course will be Windows you know
windows is already using machine
learning and the computer vision for
example to help you to personalize your
photos and videos it's really amazing
you think about the explosion of digital
photos on average for a Windows user in
every year
the user would take fifty two thousand
photos there's no way you can keep track
of so many photos and do something you
know with those photos and
- now with the help of AI let's throw
the video and show you what we have been
doing with windows photo in the video
today we capture more photos and videos
than ever before in history and we are
building a suite of AI driven tools
within Microsoft photos to transform the
way the next generation of Windows users
dreams captures and expresses themselves
this month we shipped a brand new search
system that uses machine learning to let
you find people places and things in
your photos to give you a starting point
for creating videos we have created
systems that automatically generate
movies from your media special effects
are some of the most coveted features by
our Gen Z audience so we are using
computer vision and AI to track objects
in your videos just ink a doodle anchor
it and watch it follow something in the
video we are excited to be bringing
differentiated experiences based on AI
and machine learning to over 250 million
devices every month everything is going
to become more intelligence as you think
about that you know managing of IO is
creating and you know all those things
but really the biggest AI delivery
vehicle in Microsoft is office 365 with
the total of a hundred fifty million the
monthly active users it's really a key
part of everyday AI you know we are
working on so I'm going to invite my
colleague Rob to come up to show you
some cool features you know what do we
do with AI office Rob Thank You Harry
hi everybody I'm Rob Howard I work in
the office product marketing team and
I'm really excited to be here today to
talk to you about the AI powered tools
we're adding the office to help people
do their best work the truth is we've
actually used AI in office for many
years you can think of features like
spellcheck and flash fill and
recommended charts that are a standard
part of the office you know and love but
with the advent of office 365 when we
took the cloud and deeply integrated it
with all the apps across office it
really accelerated our progress in AI
and as office 365 has grown it's become
one of our biggest vehicles for
delivering Microsoft AI technology to
real people and helping them get real
value out of it you'll see how we're
using that world data user data and
especially work data help save people
time help them focus on the things that
matter most to them even help them be
better writers and unlock hidden
insights in their data I'm going to
start off by showing you four of my
favorite a I powered features in office
these are features that I use every day
and you may have seen some of them but
like any good AI they've gotten better
as more and more people have used them
and I want to share with you the latest
and then I'm going to show you four new
ways we're bringing AI into office in
the coming months so let's get started
here in the latest version of PowerPoint
available as part of my office 365
subscription I'm working on a
presentation for the contoso mark 8
quadcopter and I will tell you I've
spent most of my career as an engineer
so actually actually building impactful
presentations takes more time and effort
than I'd like and just a second come
back up so building impactful
presentations takes me a lot of time and
effort and frankly design skills that I
just don't have luckily that's where
designer comes in designer lets me focus
on the content of my presentation and it
takes care of creating a beautiful
representation of my ideas so that's an
as impactful as on my audience as
possible I'll show you what I mean I'm
gonna start here on the title slide you
can see it's a little bit boring but I
have a few images that could spruce it
up and I'm gonna drop them into the
slide and normally I'd start rearranging
them cropping them resizing them to
create a layout that I was happy with
but designer is always working for me in
the background and when I add that
content to the slide it automatically
pops up for me with advice on how to lay
them out and as I click through them
you'll see it's creating these beautiful
designs that are featuring the content
I've added to the slide and it seems
really simple because designer made it
that way there's actually a lot of
really incredible stuff going on here
things like salient region detection
and facial recognition and color
analysis so you'll see that even as it's
cropping and resizing these images to
build a beautiful layout it understands
that the hand and the quadcopter are the
central point of the image and it keeps
them at the center even as it crops it
or the mobile phone and the remote
control and as it finds the darks than
the electronics and the mountains and
the Blues in the sky and the water it's
able to echo those in the design of the
slide through color analysis and if I go
to the next slide you'll see I have a
pretty long image here with a lot going
on
or a lot of different faces there's this
guy's yellow jacket here it would be
really easy as Cortana's pulling out a
square image from it for it to just take
the center or the left side but it's
actually able to recognize the one in
focus face in that image and as I page
through the designs that Cortana is
chosen for me you can see it's making
the hate the face the hero of that image
now I told you these are getting smarter
and one of the ways that designer is
getting smarter is it can deal with more
types of content so not just images but
now text as I go to the next slide
you'll see a set of development
milestones now designer is using natural
language processing to understand that
this is actually a timeline a series of
months and it's able to create for me a
beautiful representation of that
timeline that really makes the
milestones pop for my audience or I can
go to this next slide or I've got a
sequence of steps and designer
recognizes that as well and lets me
create a quick sequence diagram that
clearly outlines the flow and it's evil
even able to do things like pull out the
verbs from these steps and use them as a
quick header so I've seen how in a few
seconds I can use AI to help me create a
more impactful presentation in
PowerPoint now we're gonna switch into
word and see three more of my favorite
AI parred features already in office now
we're gonna start with another a I
powered assistant editor now editor goes
way beyond the spelling and grammar
checking that you're used to it actually
accounts it actually takes into account
machine learning natural language
processing and extensive and ongoing
input from human linguists it actually
make me a better writer if I scroll down
in this document it
see a bunch of examples of gold dotted
underlines and if I drill into them
you'll see that editor can catch
everything from overuse cliches like
think outside the box to jargon like
headhunting and even potential bias like
Youngblood and for each of these it not
only detects the problem but it suggests
a solution like maybe using new people
instead of Youngblood and if I'm
interested in learning more about that
recommendation I can drill in to see
more and get a lot of detail about its
recommendation as well as other examples
and I can customize the way that editor
works so if I really feel like I want to
hold on to my vague adjectives and my
Oxford commas I can do that in order to
preserve my personal style
now we've seen a couple of examples of
how AI is helping me create better work
but AI can also help me work more
naturally along the way one thing we see
people do a lot of is print off
documents like these and then take a pen
and write comments in the margin or mark
them up with edits and this sounds kind
of silly but it sort of makes sense it
feels really natural to use a pen and
recent research has shown us that
actually using a pen activates your
brain more deeply than using a mouse and
keyboard
especially when absorbing information
but with AI and ink editor in word we
can actually make using a digital pen
and ink feel as natural as paper just
without all the printing and scanning so
I can do things like choose a red pen
and of course I can write in the margin
but this pen is actually better than a
real pen and that I can make edits with
it like striking through this sentence
and those edits are automatically
effected in the document I can even go
and change to a highlighter an ink
editor understands that I no longer want
to strike something out but add emphasis
to it and I can use gestures like a
circle or a scribble an ink editor
understands exactly what I intended so
now I've done my editing I actually want
to add a little bit more content to this
document you see I need to go get a
project milestone table and a fork
chart and I know that these are things
my colleagues were working on in other
documents so normally what I do here is
I'd leave word I've gone to another tool
like Outlook or onedrive or SharePoint
to go and search for that information
once I finally found the document I
would go drill through it and find the
table that I needed or the chart I was
looking for I copy that out I come back
to Word and I and insert it that would
really break up the flow of my work but
with a new AI powered feature in Word
called tap I can directly within the
flow my work in the tool I'm already
using take advantage of all of my
organization's knowledge in order to
find the right content you'll see that I
can do things now like filter down to
specific content types so I'm looking
for this milestone table I can choose
tables and the first thing that comes up
or on the first list that come up is
this fabric cam case study before I know
the project milestones are and when I
drill in you'll see that it's not the
entire document it's actually breaking
down the specific elements that I might
want to reuse and here I see that
project milestone table that I can add
to my document with a single tap and
because it's still a full feature table
I can style it to look good in this
particular document now this cash flow
forecast chart didn't show up as one of
the top items well that's okay because
tap is actually tied into personalized
search powered by onedrive and
SharePoint so that when I type in
forecast I'm going to get results that I
have access to and ones that are most
meaningful and relevant to me so you'll
see that the cash flow forecast is
actually the top item here I can drill
in and again find that chart add it to
my document and because it's a full
feature chart inside a word I can do
things like add a trendline again
without having to leave the flow of my
work so now I've shown you my floor
favorite a I powered features already in
office I'm going to switch to what's
coming next now we're actually going to
start inside of Excel now if there's one
thing we've learned from our work in AI
it's that data is an incredibly valuable
resource and with hundreds of millions
of people using Excel there is a lot of
data in Excel spreadsheets and a lot of
the data looks like this it's a simple
table but there's a lot of columns teams
category type line items
and I don't looking at it get a sense of
how this data works what are the trends
what are the ways that these different
categories and columns affect the values
and I could of course use all the tools
in Excel to go create charts and pivot
tables to analyze it in a lot of
different ways but that would take me a
lot of time even as an Excel expert but
with insights which is coming to office
insiders this month I have an AI powered
assistant that will do all that legwork
for me so I can run insights on this
particular data set and really quickly
get a sense of how it works I can see
things like spend increases over time I
can see that if I break down this data
by type payroll has a significantly
higher spend than anything else
and if I drill into more insights I can
see deeper things like if I isolate just
stock compensation I can see a really
significant outlier and I might want to
drill into that further so I'm gonna hit
insert chart and insights will actually
automatically create a pivot table for
me in Excel tied to this data showing me
this exact insight I can mouse over here
and I can see the outlier occurred on
September 2013 but I really want to
understand the source of that so I can
use excels functionality and pivot
tables to break it down by team and
immediately I can find that the
engineering team is responsible for that
outlier and I can go and investigate
further so in just a few seconds I was
able to understand this data set and
find a few key insights that I may want
to investigate further alright now we're
gonna switch gears to things that are
truly bleeding-edge and in fact so
bleeding edges I'm gonna connect to a
Deb's machine in Dublin in order to show
it to you earlier we saw how in tap I
can use organizational knowledge in
order to more quickly access what I need
and incorporate it into my own work now
we're going to see how word online can
connect to that in order to help you
understand your company better that
organizational knowledge can be a
barrier in addition to a help I know at
companies like Microsoft like probably
every large company it can sometimes
feel like we have our own language
especially when it comes to acronyms
when you move teams or work with
different groups it can be a barrier to
understanding
and we're now connecting word online
deeply with the Microsoft graph and the
work knowledge that it has so that when
I open a document like this word online
can use that knowledge pulling from the
emails that I have access to and the
documents I have access to to
automatically identify acronyms in the
document and then within the tool I'm
already using identify them for me
so I can see AI n R means artificial
intelligence and research and that it
was found from my email or I can see
things like NPS means Net Promoter Score
and it's found it from files that I have
access to in my organization but if I
have one of these that I still don't
quite understand I cbpo means business
planning and operations but what exactly
is that I can even see exactly the
source of the information and get an
expert excerpt to understand that
business planning and operations
actually a team at Microsoft
alright so now I'm gonna show you my
last two demos and they're both in
Outlook Outlook and recent features
inside of outlook like focus inbox has
done a lot of work to help me spend less
time managing my inbox and more time
focusing on what matters to me
and soon outlook is going to show me
Outlook it's gonna help me do that
within an email if I open up this email
here you'll see it's got a lot of text
but we're actually going to use natural
language processing to identify the
action items in this text automatically
open up the email
so I've got a quick video that I can
show you on this one instead like I told
you this is bleeding edge stuff that's
coming soon oh there we go it actually
popped in so you can see that as I'm
looking through this email we're using
natural language processing on the email
to identify the action items in it
automatically so you can see the
underlines under did you see the update
the partner sent us and if I mouse over
one of these action items you can see
it's providing suggested responses and
these aren't canned responses it's not
just yes no maybe it said did you see
the update the partner sent us and the
responses are things like yeah I saw it
or no what was it
so it's tailored to the specific action
item and when I say no what was it
outlook automatically creates a reply it
quotes that action item and it inserts
my reply directly inline and I can do
that throughout the entire email
responding to each of these action items
so I can really quickly make sure I'm
covering all the action items and
respond to them even on the go the last
feature I want to show you is an Outlook
mobile and I have a feeling that this
feature was built exactly for me anybody
who works with you will tell me that I
am a perpetually late person I have a
tendency to schedule meetings back to
back I don't really take into account
how much time it will take me to travel
between them and it often happens that
by the time the outlook reminder shows
up to tell me I need to be there in 15
minutes it is going to take me way too
long to get across town luckily Outlook
and Cortana will soon solve that problem
for me you can see that Cortana is
giving me a notification that I need to
be leave by 505 to arrive on time for
dinner with friends and it's telling me
it's gonna take me 24 minutes to get to
the lake house based on my current
location and my current traffic
conditions so I know I'm not late and I
can even force touch into that
notification so I can see a route to the
destination that I'm going to and deep
link into my favorite mapping
applications to get directions so I was
a quick lap around all of the AI infused
features in office but really that's
just a drop in the bucket we've been
hard at work
adding AI to office for years and there
are literally dozens of features that
are AI powered
you'll see things like quick starter and
researcher you'll see things like my
analytic
Inc - math Inc - shape one of my
favorites math assistant if you come
over to the booth we'll tell you all
about the full story of office and AI so
thank you very much okay thank you very
much Rob it's just a lot of very
exciting you know AI features that we
you know already infused into Microsoft
products like office 365 but at
Microsoft we also want to make sure that
we can offer this kind of incredible AI
experiences in the to our partners and
the developers now how can we help them
tributes you know just as exciting a I
applications
I've talked earlier about AI platforms
and other things I also want to mention
that in a key to making great a I apps
is the data that's where you know
actually Microsoft is in a unique
position to offer our partners
developers and the partners to help them
de beauté AI applications by providing
them Microsoft graphs
it includes an award knowledge graph
like what you can get from bing and the
LinkedIn and also work knowledge graph
data from office 365 dynamics now
imagine that you know all our customers
our customers and partners you know they
can combine Microsoft graphs with their
own you know business data and knowledge
about their own users to build
incredible AI applications you know for
their customers for the employees and
for their business so we feel very very
excited about these opportunities there
that we can work together and the one
particularly unique thing about a
Microsoft is that we have worked long in
the heart to bring many of these graphs
you know together contained within a
compliance boundary that actually
conforms to our privacy compliance and
also data policies that's very very
important to enterprises so those
investments really underscore what we
have been doing you know in Microsoft AI
in the research those the five things
actually I talked it to you today I just
want to finish my presentation by
mentioning
you know some also important and
exciting topics nowadays as people talk
about AI developments in partnership in
society and also in ethics so as we
embrace this AI frontier you know we
have to acknowledge that you know
concerns about AI dee' exist and it's
actually important that we have some
universal design principles and values
that help guide our thinking our design
and development at the microsoft we take
in the ethical approach to AI design
sincerely and seriously our principled
approach is actually very critical you
know we do those things thoughtfully and
the young uh trustworthy way posts
inside Microsoft and also outside for
example internally you know we have
organized an advisory committee that
helps ensure the hearings of these
principles in our own AI development and
externally we recognize that we cannot
do that alone
so we co-founded the partnership on AI
just over a year ago this is actually a
nonprofit organization where you see you
know many leading tech companies and
academia civil societies and many many
nonprofit organizations who actually
care about the future of AI development
so this is actually set up to study
formulate and the share the best
practices on AI technology for all of us
so we also believe that we need to give
back as we develop AI so I'd like to
take this opportunity to thank our
natural ists
you know who is a great partner in our
AI for Earth's program they are here
today I encourage you to stop by their
booths to talk to them what they do for
our society and finally I would say as
the first generation to live with AI
will play a very unique role in shape
shaping the future as we will do so
you know that is actually thoughtful
that is really our number one focus see
Microsoft so these are lots we don't
really know about the AIC impact yet but
what we do know is that AI has a lot of
potential to really improve lives and
it's already happening now so let me
share a story with you about how AI has
given voices to those who otherwise
would have had none
it's risky symbols as a communication
app for people who are non-verbal
and it supports them in expressing
themselves Roman my youngest brother has
low functioning autism he finds it
difficult to communicate and can get
very upset if he can't make himself
understood
I took what we used our home with some
symbols that my mum would print out
laminate cutouts take velcro and put
them in some folders and I just thought
I could make that easier if we did it on
an app so more fun for Rowan because he
loves technology the underlying IO
technology which SwiftKey symbols uses
is the same technology which powers a
SwiftKey keyboard or we use a art
technology to be able to learn from the
user's behavior to see what they like to
use in terms of their own style of
language to predict what's going to come
next
it works by having a library of symbols
that you can pick and choose to build
your sentence and each symbol has a word
associated with it and that we used
SwiftKey AI predictive technology to
learn what you've used previously
sentences that you've previously built
and then we surface what word you might
want next and what symbol you might want
next to build your sentence we developed
it alongside Riverside school which is a
school specializing in learning
difficulties to be able to express what
they want without prompting is a really
big thing
[Music]
we have so many people's who are
non-verbal but still have so much to say
I think I can just make everything in
life more efficient so you can enjoy
life to the max there's no better
feeling than to hear a child say
something that they wanted to say and
the look on their face after they've
been able to say it you can't really
beat that because that's them expressing
themselves and that's really what you
want from them it's joyous I don't think
I can think of a better word for it it's
complete joy and celebration it's really
an incredible time walking on AI and the
use AI to amplify human ingenuity and
then we're very excited to work on those
things that a Microsoft thank you very
much again for joining us today you know
please you know if you have time hang on
here check out all the boozes thank you
very much